or maybe I misunderstood no it's like at
what point is a life of life so like
when does fundamental we protect the the
mother's life no so I guess that's why
I'm saying like I think there's Parts
where we would all agree like everyone
in this room would say the day before
like a week before you give birth no
that's that's too far right there's no
one that disagrees so my question is at
what point does a life become a life so
when when should abortion be legal if
you got to pick the laws tomorrow
and that's why I showed you the the
pamphlet so you could see the stages of
development so like at what point yeah
like my back question to that was and I
think we've gone around and a giant Loop
was what scientifically decided at that
point so that I can have some
information to face an opinion on
because I don't know I don't understand
why 20 why 26 weeks who decided that and
why so it's not really hard for me to
put an opinion on something like I don't
know normally because it was politicians
I mean I think I mean but what was that
like you were in the U.S oh so I'm from
the US
um but women sway elections so a lot of
times if like if they if people running
can say
um
they can run on abortion rights they can
get when women are 55 percent of the
population and they overwhelmingly in
the U.S 68 vote Democrat and so that's
how they win elections is by saying oh
you get more abortion rates more
abortion rights and so that that's what
I would guess but I don't know but not
even a voting issue in this nation
that's all yeah no what up like
your question to me is I still find it
hard to answer because I still don't
know from that response as to like why
22 weeks was decided by science
I think it was viability so when when if
the if the child can survive outside of
the mother's womb okay so as we said
around and that used to be 28 weeks I
believe
on its own without a mother basically
yeah and as as technology develops
obviously that's happening earlier and
earlier yeah and again like before they
couldn't really see when they didn't
have scans as well that it used to be
higher but they lowered it when we
started to see the child by the time
you're 24 weeks pregnant the baby has a
chance of survival if they're born most
babies born before this time cannot live
because their lungs and other vital
organs are not fully developed enough
um but I think in the UK you said it's
26 weeks or 24. 24. and I want to say
the earliest pregnancy that survived is
like 21 or 22 it's like two weeks before
whenever it's legal here okay so by
still based on that information
when a baby can survive on his own
without affecting anyone else's human
rights
then it's life
until that point you're you're choosing
a life over a life would you would you
agree it's too late here since there's
been babies that have survived before
what age is it here
no it's it's more legal here like in the
US it depends on the state but um and a
baby has survived at 22 weeks how many
babies it's rare it's not what was the
circumstances that that baby was born
and do we actually know the exact
perception I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure
they had a lot of medical care I'm sure
that's not common
um but then it kind of goes back to like
are people more valuable that have
access to Medical Care
so it you know but so I was just I need
time to find I need to pretend to
process that question because that's
like a whole nother unpacking yeah you
know like
everyone I believe should have access to
like government-funded Medical Care
everyone in all countries I don't
believe that anyone should be
prioritized or negligized based on their
anything at all apart from where they oh
situation because you wouldn't give that
same right to a child in the womb say
that again sorry
um I'm saying apart from you said anyone
but you're so in that you're assuming
that the child in the womb is not a
person I'm not assuming that I
acknowledge that is a human that it is
growing but it is it's one right it's
one human right or another right you're
you're saying that the mother's human
rights have to be sacrificed for that of
something else that is actually not its
own isn't that isn't that motherhood
it's like putting your kids before you
it's unconditional love yeah
so we sacrifice the child
are we sacrificing the child or we
sacrificing the mother would you prefer
to sacrifice the mother over the child
and no one's I don't think anyone here
is advocating for killing the mother no
so then where's the sacrifice on that
side of it
I I agree with pearl mothers have to
make sacrifice all the time no I'm not
arguing that the mother should pass I'm
just saying like I think I thought I
heard you say mental health yeah so yeah
and I I just feel like so um that little
backstory I'm one of um 10 kids oh
um and my um my parents got my mom got
pregnant when she was 17. wow um and all
by the same father of interest
um so we adopted three
um so we took in three kids and they um
biologically seven but one brother I
didn't find out about until I was 22.
wow because that my mom um they were so
young that they gave that kid up for
adoption
and then they re and I didn't know he
existed until I was 22. wow so I was
kind of like what if I yeah last week
but it's kind of like
um so I just like look at my mom and I'm
just like
you know it wasn't about her like it was
about her kid first and like I don't
know
like you you would agree that um
a woman should sacrifice her human
rights that include mental health
effects if we including mental health
under the human right I don't think that
you should
um for kill I'm not saying like kill the
mother but I if if mental health yeah
you are killing a part of her that's why
people choose it right
you are killing a part of a woman
when
you're taking away the twists for her I
think children um I I don't I mean I
think you women like you kill a part of
a woman when you get an abortion I mean
listen to their stories yeah so so it's
but do I think I mean I can't tell
people what to do and how to live it's
legal so that's pro-choice but no no I'm
saying like I don't have any say in it
how it is now but I'm saying mental
health yeah stick it out give the kid up
for adoption my mom came back from it
she she had 10 kids and the started they
started a multi-million dollar business
and they're broke broke dead broke they
found a great family my brother just got
married they just he just had his first
kid how is your brother like like he's
great he's phenomenal he's like actually
have a good like does he have like
himself and he yeah is that because he
had money no my parents were not like
they um they were poor so they had
um like they they didn't grow up with
money my dad was one of 13. my mom was
one and I were catholic I don't really
believe in birth control
have you ever been on the pill but
um not really no um I just
careful I don't know
um but
yeah I mean I just see my mom and she
just put it was always like family
this is why I say okay it was always
family like before
um first and so even though it was
really it was super embarrassing for her
she was 17. she was like the the family
like everyone kind of like no one else
had done that in the family you know and
it was really embarrassing but like she
always knew that it was about like it
wasn't about her it was bigger than her
and now that I see like what Greg turned
out to be I just think it would be
yes
okay this is why
um I just think it would be like a shame
if she'd aborted him because like he you
know he grew up he just had his first
kid he just got married see a grave
adoption like that's like aligned with
like uh if if someone has chosen that
they don't want to continue through to
like full-time pregnancy and you would
agree that it would be okay to put them
up for adoption so therefore give give
them away but still allow them yeah and
do you know how many families like it I
think it's gonna
there are going to be with women like
the age of first marriage average age of
first marriage is 31 in the UK 90 of
your eggs are gone by 30. they're going
to be a lot
a lot of women that want to adopt
there's a lot of kids to adoptler all
right yeah and like a lot of times like
the argument I hear is oh pro-life
people don't do anything with adoption
but every like the most pro-life people
I know have been involved in adoption
like my parents adopted three kids and
it's always it's always the pro-choice
people that never adopt it do you think
that like the uh Narrative of adoption
this is like completely neutral stance
has been like force-fed by the
government like depopularize
um what do you mean
um
like lower the population basically yeah
do you think there's other uh beings
that force that are feeding the
narrative and funding the there's just
too much [ __ ] that like lines up like I
don't know in the in the US it's
actually it's actually really creepy
um because as I was saying earlier
um I mean birth control was developed in
the 1960s then they then they develop
abortion
um I don't know if adoption like goes
into that because I'd imagine if people
want a population control they would
encourage abortion over adoption
um but
now in the US it's actually really like
Margaret Tanger was a eugenicist and
that's the number one provider of
Planned Parenthood and her her goal was
to exterminate the black population and
she's doing it the black population
would be double today in the U.S and 80
of planned parenthoods are located
located in a minority neighborhood and
when you think about it like if a normal
company that was how they were founded
people would be up in arms but nobody
cares and it's like a genocide that's
happening in front of our eyes and they
they might like they would have
marketing plans that talked about like
this is how we Market it to low-income
women this is how we Market it says like
you know they they denounce it but it's
like if you say oh we're not doing it
but you're still doing the same thing
it's like I
but you know no one cares
and because it's like a woman's right to
choose and it's interesting because I
don't know if you've looked at like the
marketing language that they talk about
where it's like they
instead of calling it a baby they'll
call it a fetus and they do that like
language is important and they do that
so people aren't as aware of what
they're doing and it's kind of like you
know when she said she had her abortion
and it came out and it was a full a full
child she had no idea do you think that
like the uh abortion
companies or services and set apart
there and intentionally hide the visual
graphic side of it for that or do you
think they've heard someone come to them
and say I don't want this this is my
choice and then they are protecting
their mental health which is what
they've come to say that they can't have
it for
um 100 I think too many people I just I
just think it's a business and I just
think they're trying to make and and
there's a girl that quit Planned
Parenthood that came out and talked
about this how um what they do is they
put you on birth control that doesn't
really work so how many girls take the
pill at the same time every day and they
try to push those and then what they'll
do is they'll then push abortion and
they're supposed to push like a like say
this is your option for adoption this is
this this is that but they don't really
do that they just push abortion and then
they get paid yes that's what she said
in the UK in the US and why like they
they say oh we have all these different
services but why are the Planned
Parenthood Clinic shutting down in the
U.S if that's true when Roe versus Wade
was passed if it's just one of many
services I think that you say the same
thing
I don't um the UK know they're
government funded yeah so there you go
to NHS 90 I think it says so it's not a
business driven decision here in the
same way but still there's people who
have got those
um kind of contracts so Mary soaps and
b-pass have uh abortion industries that
are have got those contracts and they
have like we could like Google the
profits of their company and actually
see whether they are profiting from the
decisions based and therefore give like
an in an intention as to why they would
hide the graphics and visuals behind it
I know obviously the experience that you
guys I think I think about okay think of
it imagine you're you're selling
something and your goal is to make money
yeah I don't I don't necessarily think
that every person that works at Planned
Parenthood is thinking about Eugenics
right I don't necessarily but I do think
people in general want to make money so
if you were going to start a Planned
Parenthood and you put it in you put it
somewhere right and you found out that
you lose 50 of your customer base let's
I'm just doing a number I don't know
what they actually are but let's say you
lose 50 percent of your customer base
and you get paid let's say a thousand
dollars per abortion so if there's 20
customers that come in you could get
twenty thousand dollars
um and let's say so you can make twenty
thousand dollars without showing them
anything
or you can make ten thousand dollars and
show them stuff what are you what are
you gonna do yeah is my guess but I
don't I don't actually know and in the
on the UK well the UK is so privately
fun so in the U.S sorry in the in the UK
like you have to understand there's
still government contracts so like right
now I have a private business like I I
own the studio this is like just me but
let's say I wanted to be get fun I'm
looking when I go to the us about
getting seeing if like different cities
could give us funding potentially and
you still have to like bid for a
contract so if you want to
go I don't know into sell missiles to
the government like as many of you know
I was just ban
talk and
Ties on
a
worm
you want to help please consider sending
a super thanks below every donation
helps and it helps make what we do
possible